invagination is one type of
morphogenetic movement which involves a
group of cell or tissue to fold inwards
so in folding of a sheet of cell is
simply known as invagination this
happens during gastrulation and during
invagination cells move inward this is
very similar
when you poke a rubber ball with a
finger there is a indentation which
forms and these processes are similar
invagination is one type of
morphogenetic movement among many other
types that possibly can happen during
gastrulation invagination is found in
amphioxious or let's say sea urchin
during Sea Urchin Development the
blastula invaginates and form the
arkenteron cavity eventually the
gastrulation happens and different
layers are formed
watch the full video to know more